so let's have a go this together now I
started off nice and gentle so I give
you a function and then I asked you to
evaluate that function at x equals
negative 3 right so f of negative 3
equals and hopefully you were okay to do
this substitution in here negative 3 all
squared just becomes 9 you add your 3
and you get 12 so far so good
right and then I said in a seemingly
unrelated way oh and then please sketch
it ok now I'm not to show you what the
sketch looks like it actually has all of
the information from the rest of the
question more or less all of it on there
so it's gonna spoil a few things but
we'll discuss it as we go I will point
out there just have a look at your graph
right now actually not just look at
yours look at the husband's next to you
and I want you to have a quick look at
what kind of information they placed on
that graph cuz you need a fair bit of
information to know that it's this graph
and not any other let me show you mine
ok so we all had a parabola again I know
there's lots information on here that I
had to pre draw but we'll get to it in a
second you've got the parabola but
importantly I think most people are ok
to have put that intercept on there
which was by the way what what's the
intercept it's 3 right because the
normal x squared and it's been
translated vertically upwards so that's
um that's at 3 right there hey most
people were ok to instinctively put that
on but if that's the only piece of
information you have for scale it could
be a whole bunch of different parabolas
it could be x squared plus 3 which is
what we're suggesting but it could have
been 2x squared plus 3 or 3x squared
plus 3 or another variety of different
things so that's why I asked you right
at the starter question to find a point
right now you didn't have to put this
point you could have put another point
like 1 comma 4 that would have been on
the parabola or 2 comma 7 that would've
been on the parabola but you found this
one already so why not use that as your
point for scale question
[Music]
yep so just making sure you see where I
got this room right I asked you to
evaluate when X is negative 3
what's the function equal to you've got
an answer of 12 and what that tells you
is a pair of coordinates right maybe 3
comma 12 they go together so that's the
point I decide to put on there okay all
right happy time so you've got a rough
sketch I think the next thing I asked
you was to differentiate right so what
was your what was your derivative
it was just 2x it's a fairly simple
derivative and then I asked you to
differentiate again which gave you just
- ok so it's just a constant Instron
interesting ok
now the next thing that you got
requested to do was to take those two
derivatives that you just got and then
evaluate them at that same spot that I
asked you about up above you know where
the point is but you you haven't got any
information about what it's doing at
that point so we're going to evaluate
this right so let's take each of these
two derivatives I'm gonna grab a new
color here so f dash of negative 3 I'm
still substituting in the same value but
I'm substituting it into something
different not f of X I'm substitute into
f dash so of course you all have a value
which is minus 6 negative 6 great now a
few of you asked me when we got to this
point you're like well what's going on
here right like when that was the exact
sound you make when you're trying to
substitute in negative 3 you're like
this there's no X's to substitute into
no problem if there's no axis then
you've sort of done the substitution
already it's just equal to 2 it's always
equal to 2 no matter what x value you
put in it the way we would say it is
it's independent of X so since there's
no X's you're always going to get a
second derivative off - no matter where
you are okay
all right so now we've done a we've done
B we don't see the last thing which was
just to see if you could bring all the
language together
graphing last topic I said solve when
the derivative is greater than 4 and
then show me where that is on your
sketch so let's just quickly do it here
I've got some space whoops
our derivative as you worked out earlier
was 2x so to solve when the derivative
is greater than 4 I'm gonna solve when
that's greater than 4 yes
and then as you noticed you're like oh I
don't want to X I just want X so I'm
going to divide both sides by 2 that's
all fine it's positive
so you just get X is greater than 2
there's a couple of different ways to
show that and I didn't I wasn't hyper
specific about this on in the question
one way you can represent an inequality
is using a number line right now this is
a this is an x value here X is greater
than two right so we would use the X
number line the horizontal axis so you
could for example and if you haven't
done this you're welcome to join me you
could find where 2 is like so do you
remember this is actually all the way
from last year and then you're saying
greater than 2 so I'm going to the right
is that okay I drew a hollow circle on -
why is it hollow because she's not
included it's not greater than or equal
to it's just greater than okay that's
one way to show it another way that I
thought well we have the graph here so
why don't just really have a look at it
you might notice now and I didn't ask
you to do this so don't worry if you're
like why is that on there and a lot of
mine I actually have got a whole bunch
of the derivatives all along the curve
and this is calling back to when we did
this last lesson we were looking at
different values of the first and second
derivative what are those red arrows
looking down on the left hand side what
do they mean it's a negative gradients
we've got a decreasing function on the
left hand side yeah and then right down
the bottom it happens to be the
y-intercept you've got a what's that
called right the bottom a stationary
point so your grades not going up it's
not going down the tangent is horizontal
at that point and then lastly it sort of
picks up and you can see they're all
green over there they're all increasing
but I wanted to know when they're
increasing at a rate greater than 4 so
that's why you can see they're like all
the steep sections are ever the
right-hand side in UK with that